with mountains in the background
the Bulgarian capital and it's perhaps
most famous landmark the Alexander
Nevsky Cathedral Sofia has been shaped
by 7,000 years of history under the
Roman Byzantine and Ottoman Empire's
Stanislav can tick off is an actor and
tour guide in Sofia he's very optimistic
about the city's future
ten years ago Sophia was more great now
it's like more colorful more vivid a lot
of interesting places a lot of cultural
events occurred here man Vitosha can be
seen from all over Sofia at least when
the clouds don't block the view
Stanislav can take offs tour group
begins the day with a visit to Sofia's
oldest market the women's market farmers
from all over Bulgaria sell their
produce here as well as unusual
souvenirs this metro station is called
serdika which was the Roman name for
Sofia while building the station workers
found remains of the original city and
simply left them on display less than
100 metres from the Roman excavations is
the banya bashi mosque built by the
ottomans and right next door the
Sephardic synagogue the Jewish and
Muslim communities in Sofia are now
relatively small but the buildings still
have great significance in the city what
we saw so far a mosque a synagogue two
Christian Orthodox churches really
really close to each other that's why we
like to call this square here the square
of Tolerance because we like to say that
there only ones don't throw away from
each other but they never throw stones
at each other if you start to feel a
little cold during your winter tour
Sophia's thermal springs are never far
away the public baths are no longer in
use but anyone is free to sample the hot
natural mineral water
next it's on to the presidential palace
and then one of the city's best kept
secrets the Church of st. George or the
rotunda as it's known locally can you
guess why this Roman complex together
with this church was surrounded by this
building like this to keep it secret
exactly to hide it I told you that the
communist guys they were not really keen
on religion because either you have the
godlike communist leader like Lenin
Stalin or you have got the Byzantine
frescoes inside the early Christian
church are up to a thousand years old
they survived Sophia's checkered history
and the many layers of paint who was
only joined the 20th century that they
were once again uncovered
sofia is probably the most underrated
place in europe a lot of history are not
spectacular things like to be seen here
so I will divide all oh people of the
world to come and see the beauty of our
video Bulgaria was ruled by the
Communists for nearly 50 years until
1990 today the museum for socialist art
serves as a reminder of life under the
communist regime after their busy tour
the group are ready for a hearty meal at
a traditional restaurant called the crux
ma Bulgaria's rich history is also
reflected in the local cuisine typical
Eastern European dishes are mixed with
spices from the Middle East the
Bulgarian kebab made of pork is very
typical darkness falls early during
winter but there's still plenty to see
and experience the Friday Bar is one of
the most popular pubs in Sofia tour
guide stanislav is now an actor on stage
together with friends
the party atmosphere is contagious even
for those of us who don't understand a
word of Bulgaria